Das ist ein ganz schöner Schuss. Das ist ein ganz schöner Schuss.
Das ist ein ganz schöner Schuss.
Alles klar, Andy, sehr schön, flüssiger Stickstoff haben wir noch eine Möglichkeit. Gibt es noch andere Chemikalien, die man zum Türöffnen benutzen kann?
Nein, nicht Chemikalien. Da gibt es ja immer noch die Feuerwehr-Variante.
Die ist aber dann mit einem großen Hammer die Tür aufmachen, oder?
Nein, ein langes Brecheisen. Auf dem Rückweg des Einsatzes ziehen sie das klassischerweise hinter sich her. Das ist so ein langes Eisen, zwei Meter lang, deutlich schwer. Und damit rennen sie einfach auf die Tür zu, hauen auf Höhe des Schlosses zwischen Tür und Rahmen. Und dann sind die meisten Türen offen.
Das ist dann aber einfach pure Gewalt.
Ja, weil es brennt, muss schnell gehen. Die haben keine Zeit, eine Stunde, keine Schlossung.
Ist schon klar, aber ich kann dir sagen, das ist irgendein physikalter Trick mit Hebelwirken. Nein, das ist einfach nur pure Gewalt. Um noch mal ganz kurz auf die Karte zurückzukommen, weil wir über verschiedene Materialien gesprochen haben. Ich habe mal gehört, das Material von Plaste, Getränke, Cola, irgendwas, Flaschen eignet sich da sehr gut. Wenn es mal schnell geht, muss man nichts zur Hand hat. Ist da was dran? Nein?
Doch? Habe ich noch nie gehört, kann ich mir aber vorstellen.
Habe ich auch schon gehört und funktioniert auch ganz gut.
Also die Materialanforderungen sind quasi flexibel und gleichzeitig stabil.
Wo wir bei Materialien sind, bei dem Draht, da gibt es auch so zwei Klassiker. Das eine sind Fahrradspeichen und das andere sind die Metallstreifen im Scheibenwischer.
Ja oder noch eine Alternative, die von den Straßenkehrmaschinen, von den Bürsten, die Borsten sind auch so lange Stahldinger. Die sind auch sehr geeignet.
Ja, aber es stehen mehr Autos und Fahrräder rum.
Das ist richtig.
Entschuldigt Leute, ihr sollt nicht von anderen Fahrrädern und von anderen Autos die dünnen Drähte da, ja? Das ist wie mit der Tür, nur eure eigene.
Wenn man die Nachbarn fragt, kann man sich das ja borgen und die mal ein neues kaufen.
Nachbar kann ich mir mal eine Fahrradspeiche von dir borgen. Ich glaube, das könnte zur Verwirrung führen. Aber gut, über die mechanischen Schlösser haben wir jetzt ganz viel geredet, also über die Türschlösser vor allem. Ich möchte jetzt gerne zu einem anderen Punkt kommen. Erst mal möchte ich sagen, ruft an. 0331 70 97 120 mit euren Schlossgeschichten. Es ist schon irgendwie ein oder zwei Leute gab's, die zwischendurch aufgelegt haben. Müsst ihr nicht, ihr müsst ein bisschen Geduld haben, aber ihr kommt auf jeden Fall dran. Ich würde jetzt noch mal auf den Daumen zu sprechen kommen. Den Daumabdruck, bzw. den Fingerabdruck, mit dem man auch ein Schloss sichern kann. Wie sicher das ist?
Also Fingerabdrücke sind generell eine ziemlich bescheuerte Idee. Es geht damit los, dass bei einigen Schlössern, man kennt das vielleicht aus einem schlechten Film, da ist so ein Fingerabdrucksensor und dann kommt James Bond und haucht so ein bisschen auf den Sensor drauf und dann sieht man den Fingerabdruck wieder und dann macht er irgendwie so ein bisschen Vuvu und dann geht die Tür auf. Das funktioniert bei manchen wirklich.
Entschuldigung, wie? Ist das auch auf das Schloss drauf?
Ja, du hinterlässt doch Fingerabdrücke. Wenn du irgendwie mit deinem Finger irgendwo hintaschst, dann hast du einen Fingerabdruck, der sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass an den Stellen, wo dein Finger so ein bisschen eine Erhöhung hat, Fett kleben bleibt und an der Vertiefung klebt hat, kein Fett. Und dem Moment, wo du dahin hauchst, kondensiert das Wasser nur an der Stelle, wo kein Fett ist. Und dann entsteht ein Bild des Fingerabdrucks. Und es gibt tatsächlich Sensoren, die sind so billig, dass das ausreicht und dann sagt das Ding, ja klar, ist der richtige Finger. Also ist dann auch schon gleich der passende Finger, der das Schloss aufmacht, auf dem Schloss drauf. Also großartig.
Also am besten finde ich da Fingerabdruckscanner an Laptops, die ja voll Fingerabdrücke sind.
Besonders mit dem neuen Trend, wo nicht nur die Displays, sondern auch die Deckel in Klavierlack-Optik ausgeführt werden.
Also bei anderen ist es schon ein bisschen komplizierter. Es gibt da verschiedene Techniken. Unter anderem, also entweder optisch, optisch haben wir gerade gehabt, das ist scheiße, wenn man einfach bloß ein Bild macht, kann man dann auch ein Bild von einem Fingerabdruck drüber halten, das geht dann auch. Die etwas besseren funktionieren kapazitiv. Also die erkennen sozusagen, wo eine Berührung auf dem Sensor ist. Muss man sich so vorstellen wie ein Kamerasensor, nur dass man direkt auf den nackten Sensor drauf fasst und da wo man ihn berührt, also da wo wieder die Erhöhung im Fingerabdruck ist, ist die Kapazität an der Stelle anders und dann kann man das da rausjagen und irgendwie ein Bild des Fingerabdrucks erstellen.
Also kapazitiv ist, ist quasi sowas wie eine Art Smartphone Display.
Genau, nur viel feiner aufgelöst. Also eigentlich wie wenn man seine Digitalkamera aufmacht und direkt auf den Sensor fasst.
Das könnt ihr ja noch mal probieren.
Technisch nahezu dasselbe. Und da muss man schon ein bisschen mehr Aufwand treiben. Da muss man nämlich eine 3D-Struktur nachbauen. Wie macht man das? Wie macht man das? Wir sind dann drauf gekommen, als wir da mal drum gebastelt haben, auf eine Folie mit einem Laserdrucker ein Bild von dem Fingerabdruck auszudrucken. Und dann setzt sich die Druckerschwärze auf der Folie ab und steht so ein bisschen über. Und dann kann man mit ein bisschen Holzkaltleim eine Schicht darüber machen, warten bis es fest ist und das dann abziehen. Und dann hat man einen Holzkaltleim mit einer 3D-Struktur drin.
Und der leitet dann auch für das Kapazitive?
Ja, wenn der nicht ausreichend leitet, muss man ein bisschen mit Grafitpulver rumspielen. Aber bei den meisten Sensoren geht es einfach so. Ja, das geht dann auch. Und bei den richtig tollen gibt es dann eine Lebenderkennung. Da steckt man also seinen Finger rein. Und dann kommen die mit Infrarotlicht und sehen da die Venen. Und dann müssen dann die Venen pulsieren, damit das alles funktioniert. Und bei den wirklich guten messen sie nach, wo die Venen sind. Aber so wirklich gute sind glaube ich auch gar nicht wirklich erhältlich am Markt. Also ich weiß nicht, ob die schon wirklich verkauft werden. Die nicht ganz so guten mit Lebenderkennung, da tut man dann einfach, nachdem man sich also dieses mit seinem Holzkaltleim den Fingerabdruck gemacht hat, sich dünn auf seinen Finger draufkleben. Dann steckt man ja einen echten Finger mit dem gesuchten Fingerabdruck rein. Und die Lebenderkennung sagt, ja, er steckt ein echter Finger drin. Und das ist auch der richtige Fingerabdruck. Und dann geht's auf.
Ich find's wirklich sehr schön. Aber sieh man das vorhin, das klang so, als ob du... Du meintest irgendwie so, ja Fingerabdrücke, da gibt's auch sozusagen gute und schlechte Sachen. Und es klang so, als ob du schon das auch für Plausibilheit anzuwenden, in bestimmten Fällen.
Na, es kommt immer drauf an, was man damit schützen will. Andreas hat ja jetzt nur viele Facetten erzählt. Und es geht halt von sehr einfachen und teilweise auch günstigen Lösungen bis zu schon sehr anspruchsvollen Lösungen. Und es ist, soweit ich informiert bin, auch eine Frage, wie in Anführungsstrichen die Auflösung ist. Das heißt, wie viele Merkmale abgefragt werden oder eingescannt werden. Und das hat einfach was mit der Praxistauglichkeit zu tun. Umso genauer das ist, umso höher ist die Fehlerquote.
Also auch, wenn der eigentliche Besitzer des Fingers da reinlegt, dann wird trotzdem ein Anarm heisst.
Also man hat die Herdplatte gefasst und dann ist ein Stückchen von deinem Fingerabdruck weg, geht die Tür nicht mehr auf.
Richtig. Und auch wie gerade man den Finger rauflegt, da sind manche Systeme auch toleranter oder intolerant. Und umso toleranter die sind, umso größer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein anderer seinen Finger drauf legt und es aufgeht.
Also ich halte mal fest, ich hatte anfangs die Frage gestellt, dass ich bei so einem In the Cloud Service Host da auf einer Webseite war, der gesagt hat, ja unsere Server sind gesichert. Da ist dann ein Biometrie-Dingens dran, also ein Fingerabdruckscanner. Das heißt, im Prinzip hat in seiner Werbung geschrieben, wir sind Schloss dran. Das sagt also über die Qualität erst mal noch überhaupt gar nichts.
Genau und irgendwie, also wenn sie explizit Fingerabdrücke geschrieben haben, auch ähnlich besonders gut ist. Mittlerweile habe ich neulich gelesen, gibt es Kameras, die gar nicht mal so groß sind, mit denen man den Fingerabdruck aus mehreren Metern Entfernung einfach vom Finger abfotografieren kann. Ja, da musst du gar nicht mal irgendwie irgendjemanden sein Wasserglas vom Podium klauen, um an den Fingerabdruck ranzukommen, sondern es reicht einfach aus, ein Foto zu machen. Und andere Systeme, zum Beispiel, es gibt ja noch Iris Scanner, wo also ein Bild des Auges gemacht wird, da ist natürlich genau das selbe Problem, dass man mit einem Teleobjektiv aus großem Abstand einfach knips. Und sich die Daten klauen kann. Dass man das Zugangsmerkmal überall hinterlässt, ist meines Erachtens das größte Problem bei den Fingerabdrücken.
Es gibt den generell, ohne in die Biometrie-Diskussionen abgleiten zu wollen, aber gibt es eine Art Schließsystem, die über biometrische, also irgendeine Körperteilerkennungserfassung funktioniert, wo ihr sagt, da könnte noch was raus werden?
Es gibt einen, der funktioniert, der ist aber ganz schön schmerzhaft für den Benutzer. Und zwar ist das eine, die Netzhauterkennung. Also wird einem mit einem hellen Licht ins Auge geleuchtet. Wenn man schon beim Augenarzt war, kennt man das.
Ach, das gibt es tatsächlich. Ich hab ja nur so einen Film gesehen, wo so ein Flash kommt, und dann wird irgendwie ein Foto von einem Herz bekommen.
Das gibt es tatsächlich. Und sie nehmen es tatsächlich auch hauptsächlich für Atombunker und so ein Scheiß, weil es irgendwie, also die Nutzerakzeptanz ist grauenhaft, weil man möchte einfach nicht zweimal am Tag mit einem echt hellen Licht ins Auge geleuchtet bekommen. So, aber das ist wirklich gut, weil da kommt man auch schwer ran.
Aber das ist trotzdem sozusagen ein bildgebendes Verfahren.
Aber es ist halt ein Merkmal, was man nicht jeden Tag mit sich rumträgt. Also wie oft kommt jemand auf dich zu und guckt dir genau auf deine Netzhaut.
Kommt drauf an, wie komische Leute du kennst. Aber gut, ich verstehe schon.
Alles klar ist. In dem Bereich muss man sich natürlich auch Gedanken machen, wer im Nachts auflauert und dann mit seinem Auge wegläuft.
Dann möchte ich ja gerade mal das Thema wieder ändern, und zwar mit Jürgen, der hier am Telefon ist, der eine Frage hat, die ich interessant finde und gar nicht selber drauf gekommen bin. Jürgen? Deine Frage ist?
Ja, meine Frage ist, ich meine, wir sind jetzt schon vom Elementaren weg. Ihr seid jetzt schon in höheren Szenen. Aber mich würde mal interessieren, wie Behörden und was weiß ich, welche Institute noch mit Generalschlüssen umgehen, wie das funktioniert. Ich meine, das ist ja nun nicht mehr mit Schlüsten, oder?
Doch, also auch. Also Generalschlüsse, es gibt ja so Volksweisheiten, dass es für jeden Schloss einen Generalschlüssel gibt. Das ist definitiv nicht so. Generalschlüssel werden gerade in größeren Anlagen, wo man sehr, sehr viele verschiedene Schließungen bewerkstellen muss, mit unterschiedlichen Merkmalen umgesetzt. Das ist einmal das Profil des Schlüssels. Also ein einfacher Zimmertürschlüssel ist sehr breit und hat einen sehr breiten Schaft- oder Schließkanal, wo man den Schlüssel reinsteckt. Und der General-Schlüssel ist sehr viel schmaler und zierlicher, sodass er in mehrere verschiedene Profile reinpasst. Der einzelne Zimmerschlüssel, der dicke, passt aber vielleicht drei Türen weiter schon nicht mal mehr ins Schloss, sodass man an diesem Schloss immer gleiche Stifte für eine andere Schließberechtigung vergeben kann. Und dann ist es außerdem so, dass in so einem klassischen Stiftzylinder dann mit sogenannten Plättchen gearbeitet wird. Also da hat man nicht nur ein Kernstift und ein Gehäuse-Stift, sondern dazwischen auch noch ein Plättchen, sodass man an zwei unterschiedlichen Stellen, also mit zwei verschiedenen Schlüsseln schließen kann.
Links und rechts. Also ich meine, dass man links und rechts dann kontaktiert.
Nee, das ist so, dass man sich das so vorstellen kann, dass die Schlüssel, da sind ja die Nasen verschieden weit reingesägt. Ein bisschen weiter, ein bisschen weniger weit. Und dadurch, dass man also nicht nur zwei Stifte hat, sondern noch so ein bisschen was dazwischen, funktioniert der eine Schlüssel, der ein bisschen weiter reingefriesst. Es sind der andere, der nicht ganz so weit reingefriesst. Es funktioniert auch. Und das kann man halt an zwei, drei Stellen machen. Und damit kann man sich dann Systeme bauen, wo ein Schlüssel bei allen Schlössern passt und ein anderer nur bei einigen, und der dritte nur bei genau einem Schloss. Das macht natürlich auch das Picken einfacher. Man hat mehr Möglichkeiten, wie man den Stift bewegen kann.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist im Prinzip ein Spiel mit den Toleranzen.
Ja, also definitiv ja. Aber irgendwo muss man ja das Ganze auch praxistauglich machen. Trotzdem ist die Tür verschlossen. Da ist wieder der Punkt, wo ich sage, man muss mal abwägen, was will man damit machen. Man kann ja an besonders wichtigen Türen auch ein zweites Schloss anbringen. Aber das kommt jetzt erstmal von einer eigentlichen Frage ab. Wie gesagt, bei diesen Plättchen, das kann man nicht nur in einem Stift machen, sondern in mehreren Stiften. Dann hat man schon sehr, sehr viele Möglichkeiten.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass wenn jetzt hier jemand die Befugnis hat, ins Haus rein zu kommen, also jetzt spricht Miethaus, dass der auch mit dem Generalschlüssel in die Wohnung kann.
Das ist in der Regel so. Auch in Wohnhäusern kann das so sein, dass es einen Generalschlüssel gibt. Dann sollte das aber im Mietvertrag drinstehen, dass der Vermieter einen Schlüssel zu deiner Wohnung hat. Im Mietbereich ist es klassischerweise so, dass man da einen sogenannten technischen Hauptschlüssel hat. Der schließt dann alle nicht privaten Räume. Also die Wohnungstüren werden dann wirklich nur von dem Wohnungsschlüssel geschlossen. Und der technische Hauptschlüssel schließt dann sowas wie Hauseingangstür, Hoftür, Kellertür, Hausanschlussraum und so weiter.
Mit anderen Wochen kann ich dann auch zu meiner Wohnungsbau-Gewätschaft gehen, wenn meine Tür zugeschlagen ist ohne, dass ich wieder reinkomme, dass die mir eine Generalsicherung wieder aufmachen.
Wenn sie so einen haben.
Meistens nicht.
Ja, aber das wäre doch, ich meine, würde doch mietvorm Mieter freundlich sein, ne?
Boah, also, das tänkt immer so ein bisschen vom Vermieter ab. Und was man so für ein Verhältnis zum hat. Also ich kenn schon Geschichten von Leuten, die dann angefangen haben an ihren Schnapsflaschen mit Bleistiftmarkierungen zu machen, weil der Vermieter immer saufen gekommen ist. Und ich zum Beispiel baue mir grundsätzlich, wenn ich irgendwo in eine Mietwohnung ziehe, erstmal meinen eigenen Zylinder ein. Und wenn ich ausziehe, kriegt der Vermieter sein wieder. Weil steht er zwar, dass er keinen Schlüssel mehr hat, aber eigentlich möchte ich nicht, dass der mich besucht, ohne dass ich das weiß.
Gerne, Jürgen, und viel Spaß und ein sicheres Wissen.
Ja, ich hatte deinem Vorzimmermensch schon noch gesagt, weil ich das so wunderbar finde. Deine Lache, wenn die mal Junge kriegt, möchte ich gerne ein.
Um Gottes Willen, jetzt kommen wir aber in Bereiche, wo ich ganz unangenehm berührt werde und auch gleich mal auflegen muss. Jürgen, vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch. So, jetzt sind wir beim Generalschüssel, Biometrie, Türen, was fehlt noch? Also, mein Autos fehlen eigentlich noch, oder?
Autos, Autos ist eine gute Sache.
Das Schönste, was ich ja neulich über Autos gelesen hab, ist... Ah nee, erzähl die erst mal.
Autos sind Wegversperren, ne?
Autos sind Wegversperren, ja.
Ist glaub ich gerade wieder zum Problem geworden. Die Diebstahlzahlen bei BMW sind wieder hochgegangen und sie müssen da jetzt mal wieder was tun. Ich muss zugeben, ich hab mich nicht im Detail mit beschäftigt. Aber das Spannende ist, dass viele von diesen Dingern ja über Funk funktionieren und einfach über die Nähe. Und dass es offensichtlich mittlerweile Leute gibt, die sich sozusagen in Anführungszeichen eine Funkverlängerung bauen. Das heißt, der eine steht bei dem Auto, der andere setzt sich dann im Restaurant unauffällig nebenan und hält es in die Nähe des Schlüssels. Und dann macht es einmal Klick und dann ist das Auto da draußen offen und auch die Schließanlage.
Naja, also man muss da ja auch unterscheiden. Es gibt ja ja verschiedene Dinge. Ganz klassisch hat es ja vor einiger Zeit erst angefangen, dass man immer noch mechanische Schlüssel hatte und dann irgendwie eine Wegfahrsperre, weil dann die Versicherungen das irgendwann wollten. Dass man also mit dem Schlüssel ganz normal die Tür aufschließt, mit dem Schlüssel ganz normal das Zündschloss bestätigt und dann ist da noch so ein ganz kleiner RFID-Transponder drin, der dann irgendwie mit dem Auto kommuniziert und das schaltet dann irgendwie auf magische Weise innerhalb der Motorsteuerung die Wegfahrsperre frei, damit man auch losfahren kann.
Funktioniert genauso wie ein Kopierschutz bei Spielen. Funktioniert auch genauso gut wie ein Kopierschutz bei Spielen.
Es kommt auf die Implementierung an.
Also ich habe genau das nämlich auch gelesen mit diesem, wir bauen uns eine Fernbedienung, die tatsächlich Autos dienen.
Das war jetzt halt, wenn man mit dem klassischen Schlüssel aufschließt, dann gab es dann irgendwann später die Fernbedienung. Da gibt es dann auch wieder verschiedene Varianten, einfach so klassisch eine Fernbedienung, die dann einen Code aussendet oder eine Fernbedienung mit dem Auto redet und die unterhalten sich dann untereinander. Da ist zum Beispiel schon seit längerer Zeit eine beliebte Angriffsmethode, dass man einfach Leute anguckt auf dem Parkplatz, wenn sie losgehen und auf ihre Fernbedienung drücken und das Auto zu schließen wollen. Dass man einfach mit irgendeinem Störsender dazwischen sendet und dann schließt das Auto nicht ab und der Mensch geht einfach los. Dann ist das Auto immer noch offen. Das war zum Beispiel lange Zeit noch sehr beliebt. Man muss also immer gucken, auch wenn man auf den Knopf gedrückt hat, ist das Auto wirklich zugegangen. Und neuerdings gibt es halt nicht einfach nur mehr Fernbedienung, schließt Auto auf, ein zweiter Transponder schaltet die Wegfahrsperre frei, sondern es gibt mittlerweile sogar Systeme. Das nennt sich dann Keyless Entry. Da sind sie jetzt alle ganz stolz drauf, auch bei BMW. Da geht das Auto einfach auf, sobald man sich innerhalb von ungefähr zwei Meter Entfernung vom Auto befindet. Also wenn man den Schlüssel in zwei Meter Entfernung vom Auto hat, geht das Auto auf und dann hat man auch keinen Zündschloss mehr, sondern es gibt bloß noch einen Startknopf, der einfach auch nur funktioniert, wenn der Schlüssel sich innerhalb von zwei Meter Entfernung befindet. Und da kann man sich vorstellen, selbst wenn man als Laie sich so ein System anguckt und überlegt, das braucht eine Funkentfernung von zwei Metern. Und Funks sind ja auch einfach bloß irgendwelche Datensignale. Datensignale kann man weiterleiten. Das bedeutet also nicht einfach nur, dass sich das Auto in zwei Meter Entfernung befinden muss, sondern im Zweifelsfall einfach nur der Empfänger des Angreifers befindet sich in zwei Meter Entfernung von dir. Das sind wahrscheinlich häufiger mal viele Menschen. Und der hat dann einen Komplizen, der mit dem Sender zum Auto geht.
Das war ja noch nicht immer so. Also früher musste man ja immer noch auf den Knopf drücken, damit das aufgegangen ist. Und so die vermeintliche Vereinfachung für den Kunden war, man muss gar nicht mehr zum Schlüsselgreifen auf den Knopf drücken, dass es aufgeht. Und das macht natürlich das Risiko aus, weil wenn man einfach auf den Knopf drücken müsste, wenn man in der Kneipe sitzt, damit der Angreifer inzwischen das Auto klopft. Aber Ding einfach ein bisschen.
Na ja, es gibt auch Leute, die als nervösend ticken mit dem Knopf spielen.
Ja, das ist eher selten.
Also mein Part ist ja der mechanische. Und bei diesen Systemen kann ja auch mal die Batterie alle sein. Deswegen haben ja alle noch meistens in diesem Schlüssel versteckt so ein Notschlüssel.
Irgendwo hinter dem Logo oder so, wenn man mal so ein System hat. Genau.
Hinter dem Logo, ja. Ich werde jetzt keinen Namen nennen, aber bei deutschen Oberklasseautos kann man auch Autos kaufen, die so 80 bis 100.000 Euro kosten. Und wo es klassisch theoretisch mögliche verschiedene Schlüssel 16 Stück gibt, von denen aber nicht alle benutzt werden. Das heißt, dass Oberklasseautos ausgeliefert werden, so mit acht verschiedenen Schließungen, die man ja mal bei haben kann und ausprobieren kann in unter einer Minute.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Du hast acht Schlüssel bei und schließt garantiert auf.
Das ist wie bei den Schreibtischschlössern, weißt du? Wenn deiner nicht passt, dann passt der vom Nachbarn, weil mehr Sorten Schlüssel gibt es gar nicht.
Für alle Autos dieses Types gibt es acht verschiedene Schlüssel und die werden einfach so sagen, willkürlich verteilt.
Genau.
Entschuldigung.
Und dafür bezahlt man richtig viel Geld.
Und das hat denn noch keiner gesagt? Also bzw. hat keiner gesagt, so wir haben das mitgekriegt. Könnte das mal ändern oder?
Das interessiert die Leute nicht.
Tja, das erklärt vielleicht auch die hohen Liesperrsraten in diesem Bereich. Okay, das ist ein urbaner Mythos, den ich mal gehört habe. Nämlich dieses jemand wettet mit jemand, dass er genau so ein Auto irgendwie schnell aufmacht. Und dann legt er einfach eine brennende Zeitung drunter. Und dann geht irgendwie so eine Not hier. Alle Passagiere müssen aus dem Auto raus können. Deswegen geht das Auto auf. Gibt es so eine Tricks auch? Also quasi, dass man sagt, dass man nicht den Schlüssel hackt?
Habe ich noch nicht von gehört, kann ich mir aber lebhaft vorstellen. Also solche Autos, da passiert ja einiges, wenn so ein Unfall passiert. Dann muss ja dann der Airbag ausgelöst werden. Dann müssen bestimmte Sachen ausgeschaltet werden, von links nach rechts gefahren, wegen der Sicherheit und so. Und wenn das Auto einen Unfall feststellt, ist auch die Tür entriegelt, damit man im Zweifelsfall rauskommt. Halte dich für plausibel. Also wenn man dem Auto vermittelt, du, da ist gerade ein Unfall, dann macht er bestimmt die Tür auf.
Also das ist definitiv so. Also bei Autos, wo die Airbags auslösen und die Systeme haben, die beim Losfahren, selbst verriegeln, im Unfallfall entriegeln die. Allerdings hatte ich von der Rauchmelder Version nicht gehört.
Wie gesagt, das ist ein Ding, das habe ich gehört, als es jemand erzählt hat von jemand, dessen Freundin, der Schipschwager und so. Das ging mir jetzt nur um diese Art des Angriffs. Also das hat gar nichts mit dem Schloss zu tun, sondern bringt das Auto irgendwie dazu, zu glauben, ich muss jetzt mal die Türen aufmachen.
Kommt sicher auch das Auto an.
Das kannte ich noch nicht, finde ich aber gut.
Könnte beim Oberklasseauto sein, wenn man so wie ich ein Auto hat, was elektronisch ein Licht, ein Blinker und ein Autoradio hat und sonst nichts, da würde es wohl nicht funktionieren.
Dein Auto hat Elektronik, mein es hat Elektrik.
Elektrik.
Jetzt geht es aber ins Detail. Ist es Absicht oder ist es einfach nur alt?
Nein, es ist einfach nur alt. Aber zu Autos wollte ich noch ein paar Geschichten erzählen. Früher sehr beliebt war die Nummer mit dem Tennisball. Und man hat ja bei Autos immer diesen Hebel, den man runterdrücken kann, wieder rausziehen kann. Je nachdem, wie das Schloss gebaut ist, gibt es einige. Dann nimmt man sich einen Tennisball, dann macht man ein kleines Loch rein. Das setzt man auf das Schloss drauf, dann haut man drauf. Dann entsteht in dem Schloss ein Überdruck und dann wird der Stift nach oben gedrückt, plopp, und dann ist die Tür offen.
Das ist ja cool. Ich hab es tatsächlich mal geschafft. Da war ich auch wirklich stolz drauf. Typische Situation, Schlüssel im Auto vergessen, Regelung zugemacht, Auto zugeworfen. Oh Gott, was jetzt? Ja, wir haben doch mal im Film gesehen, irgendwie mit Radbügeln. Haben wir tatsächlich sozusagen so einen alten Bügel genommen und den irgendwie oben durch die Tür rein gefrickelt und dann mit diesem Knopf hochgezogen.
Das macht man auch tatsächlich professionell teilweise so. Also die Profis haben dann noch einen kleinen Keil dabei mit einer Gummiumwandlung, der oben in die Tür reingetrieben wird, damit man auch Platz hat, um reinzukommen. Wieder die Geschichte mit den Toleranzen, aber total gängige Methode.
Das andere Problem ist, dass heute ja niemand mehr etwas sieht. Als ich in dem Job angefangen hab, ging es auch irgendwann mal darum, Autos zu öffnen. Dann sind wir rausgegangen auf die Straße und haben mein Auto aufgebrochen. Und da sind die Leute vorbeigelaufen, die haben uns nicht angesprochen. Also wir standen da in Zivil und haben Auto aufgemacht, wieder zugemacht, Auto aufgemacht, wieder zugemacht, Auto. Und die Leute gehen vorbei und weiter und da sagt keiner was.
Also bei uns kam tatsächlich dann, nach 20 Minuten, einer halben Stunde kam tatsächlich die Polizei. Wir hatten die Papiere natürlich in den Wagen drin, aber die haben dann ganz entspannt gewartet, bis wir das aufgekriegt haben. Haben allerdings auch nicht geholfen. Dürfen die wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht.
Aber dazu eine Anekdote, eine Bekannte von mir, fuhr in einen Berliner Bezirk und steigt aus, macht das Auto zu, Schlüssel liegt drin. Da kommen so drei Jugendliche auf sie zu und sagen so, was ist denn? Ich hab meinen Schlüssel drin vergessen, ja. Und dann meint sie, ach kein Problem, macht die Jacke auf, zack zack, Auto offen.
Tatsächlich?
Sie hat dann umgeparkt.
Was ich auch mal gesehen habe, auch bei Freunden, wir waren unterwegs, kommen wieder, plötzlich irgendwie Sachen aus dem Auto geklaut, aber Auto abgeschlossen. Alles angeguckt, alles angeguckt. Irgendwann haben wir festgestellt, am Türgummi an einer Stelle war ein kleines Loch drin. Und das war so eins der ersten Autos, die eine Zentralverriegelung hatten. Da war dann an der Seite im Türgriff der Knopf zum Fähr und Entriegeln. Da reicht es offensichtlich aus, mit einer ausreichend langen Speiche von oben durch den Türgummi durch auf den Knopf zu drücken, dann hat das Auto die Tür aufgemacht.
Wie großartig. Mir ist das auch mal passiert. Allerdings war das eine Ente und da haben sie einfach die Fenster aufgeschraubt. Ja, das fand ich. Bei der Ente geht das. Ich meine, das ist eine Ente. Das ist halt ein Stück Blech mit einem Motor drin. Aber es ist liebenswert. Und da einzubrechen. Na gut, da kann ich mich jetzt schon lange echauffieren, das müssen wir aber nicht machen. Was eigentlich in der Rubrik noch fehlt, also Türschlösser, Autoschlösser, sind noch Fahrradschlösser, oder? Gibt es da was zu sagen, was wir nicht sowieso schon hatten?
Bolzenschneider.
Ja, na da gibt es auch die etwas besseren Fahrradschlösser, da geht das dann nicht so einfach mit dem Bolzenschneider, die kosten aber auch viel Geld.
Da nimmt man einen Kabelschneider. Also Kabelschneider, die so 100er Telefonkabel durchschneiden, schneiden auch jedes Fahrradschloss durch.
Was ist 100er Telefonkabel?
Also so mit 100 Kupferdoppeladern, auch die muss man irgendwie durchschneiden und sowas gibt es auch so mechanisch zum Ratschen, was so auch nicht größer als ein Jackenärmel ist.
Und die, da kommst du durch jedes Fahrradschloss mit durch, sagst du?
Ja, ja. Ich hab letztens einen Kunden gehabt, der hatte bei mir ein sehr hochwertiges Schloss gekauft, muss ich dazu sagen. Und der kam dann an und es war richtig sauber, glatt durchgeschnitten. Und das war nicht mit einem Bolzenschneider gemacht, weil beim Bolzenschneider hat man so Quetschungen. Und es gibt halt, danach haben wir lange recherchiert, und es gibt halt Kabelschneider, die man halt auch ohne Gewerbe in die Näme kaufen kann. Und die schneiden so ziemlich alles durch. Also so auch bis richtige Durchmesser. So richtig traurig.
Es gibt ja seit einiger Zeit diese Schlösser, die man so zusammenfalten kann, diese aus einzelnen Metallstücken bestehen. Und hat mal jemand Sekundenkleber ins Schloss gesprüht, das fand ich total großartig. Mit dem Fahrradladen hat das einfach aufgeflext. Das hat halt auch noch drei Minuten gedauert, aber war natürlich ziemlich laut.
Macht richtig Krach. Und es gibt auch nur wenige sehr richtig teure Akku-Flexen. Also man hat selten so Strom dabei. Flex ist total klasse, aber Flex braucht immer richtig Strom.
Es ist eine blöde Idee, also Steckdosen vor der Tür zu haben oder da, wo man seinen Fahrradschluss steckt, ein richtig doofes Ding. Muss man sagen.
Naja, aber das Ding ist ja, man braucht es auch nicht mehr, weil es gibt ja diese Kabelschneider. Wie teuer sind die?
Keine Information. Also da gibt es sicher auch bessere und schlechte.
Wäre natürlich die Frage überhaupt, wie teuer oder billiger als eine Flex sind.
Eine Akku-Flex wohlgemerkt. Fahrräder machen sowieso nicht so viel Spaß, weil Fahrräder haben ja schon seit längerer Zeit eine Rahmennummer, die eindeutig identifizierbar ist. Aber was gerade in so kinderbeliebten Bezirken wie Prenzlauer Berg ein großes Problem ist, sind Kinderwagen. Weil Kinderwagen, dafür geben die Leute richtig Geld aus. Also so für gute Kinderwagen 500 bis 3000 Euro. Ja, es ist keine Seltenheit. Und selbst wenn man mal so im Second Hand Laden vorbeigeht und da schon richtig ramponierte Kinderwagen sieht man selten im zweistelligen Bereich. Und da gibt es richtig organisierte Gruppen. Und Leute schließen ihre Kinderwagen teilweise mit deutlich besserer Technik als Fahrräder an, weil sie sind einfach nicht registriert, haben keine Rahmennummer, können überall verkauft werden. Das ist ein echtes Problem zurzeit.
Kinderwagen, die das aber moralisch schon ganz schön verkommen, oder?
Das war so schlimm wie eine Ente aufbrechen.
Gibt es noch Moral?
Das ist eine Frage, die auch die klingeln wie in einer anderen Sendung. Überhaupt machen wir jetzt erst mal eine kurze Pause, weil das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr, wieder auf uns wartet und danach geht es weiter. Heute ist Chaos Radio, das 164. halbe Stunde haben wir noch und der Typ, der seinen Rechner gerade auf dem Pult des Nachrichtmanns hatte stehen lassen, ist Andreas vom Chaos Computer Club.
Ich bin Ikke.
So sieht es aus. Außerdem ist Henrik da. Und als Mann vom Fach der Simon. Hallo zurück. Es geht heute noch eine halbe Stunde um Schließsachen. Also wir haben schon über Türen gesprochen, über Schlösser, über wie die Tür selber aussehen muss, über Elektronik, die bei Türen mit am Start ist, über Autos, über Fahrradschlösser und jetzt haben wir noch zwei Anrufer. Mal gucken, was die noch dazu beizutragen haben. Da ist erstens der Paul. Hallo Paul. Na, hast du eine Tür aufgemacht oder ist die Tür zugegangen?
Ja, sie ist eine Zugang. Wir haben sie aufgemacht. Das war unsere alte Tür bei meinen Eltern. Die war so ein bisschen älter und da gab es zwischen Tür und Türrahmen so einen halben Zentimeter Platz. Und mit jedem bisschen stabileren Gegenstand konnten wir die relativ leicht aufmachen. Also Schraubenzieher haben wir benutzt, Spaten, Wasserwäsche, Klammer, eigentlich so alles.
Das heißt, ihr habt keinen Schlüssel mehr dabei gehabt, sondern ihr habt einfach immer so einen als Sport gemacht.
Nicht wirklich. Also man hat ja die Schlüssel eher draußen drin vergessen. Und dann muss man ja irgendwie wieder reinkommen und irgendwo zu Bekannten laufen und Schlüssel holen war irgendwie scheiße. Deswegen, na ja, in den Schuppen gegangen, irgendwie das nächste Beste genommen. Und dann eine halbe Minute später nicht mal war die Tür offen.
Aber bei euch eingebrochen ist nicht mal geworden?
Doch einmal, aber das war, da haben sie das Fenster eingeworfen.
Ja, blöd meiner Eier, hätte doch einfach durch die Tür gehen können.
Richtig, richtig.
Na gut, die war zu dem Zeitpunkt abgeschlossen. Also das durfte sie nicht sein. Also abgeschlossen durfte sie nicht sein, aber ansonsten.
Halber Zertimeter nicht schlecht. Und hast du dann, seitdem ist dir das egal oder achtest du jetzt ein bisschen mehr darauf, dass die Tür ein bisschen enger schließt?
Nö, wir haben jetzt ein neuer und das geht jetzt. Also Kumpel von mir, der ist dann irgendwie ab und zu, wenn meine Eltern nicht da waren, auch gekommen. Und ich wohne hier, war am oberen Stoffler, Klinge ist kaputt gewesen und naja, dann ist einfach, hat immer eine Straubenzieher dabei, damit er reinkommt.
Nicht schlecht.
Da muss man den Schlüssel nicht mehr unten draußen vorm Stein verstecken.
Richtig.
Also gerade bei Haustünen ist die Toleranz immer Wahnsinn.
Weil die so abgenutzt sind? Also ist das sagen, ist das eingebaut?
Ja, Wetter, schwer, groß, wackelig, kümmert sich auch manchmal keiner drum. Also es gibt ja Müllkutscher, die ja eigentlich immer einen Schlüssel haben, die einfach eine Karte haben, weil es schneller geht, als den Schlüssel rauszusuchen. Habe ich schon gesehen.
Ich mache das. Ich habe, Paul, erstmal vielen Dank für deine Haustür und viel Spaß damit noch. Danke. Bei uns an der Haustür ist neben der Tür ein Schloss in die Wand eingelassen und wir haben ein Sommer. Hat das irgendwas mit Müllmännern, Postkutschern oder irgendwas zu tun?
Das Schloss an der Wand ist die Feuerwehr.
Es ist meistens ein kleines rundes Röhrchen, so genannter Schlüsseltresor und da ist so eine Standardschließung der Feuerwehr drinne, meistens der lokalen Feuerwehr und da liegt dann ein Schlüssel von der Haustür, von der Kellertür, wahrscheinlich von den Anschlussräumen drinne. Eventuell auch von deiner Wohnung.
Na klar, die müssen überleeren, aber sie sagen, da kommt nur die Feuerwehr ran.
Oder ein Lockpicker.
Ja, ok, das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen. Mann, ihr könnt ja nicht gleich alles wegnehmen. Also gedacht ist es, dass nur die Feuerwehr ran kommt und nicht die Post oder sozusagen die Müllmänner irgendwie dafür auch Schlüssel haben.
Die Post hat eigene Schlüsselfächer.
Wie? Auch jetzt für das Haus oder wie?
Für die Haustür zumindest. Die müssen ja an den Briefkasten rankommen. Du hast dich doch sicherlich schon mal gewundert, wie die Post bei dir in den Briefkasten kommt.
Nee, nicht, weil die Postleute immer so einen großen Schlüsselring dabei haben, wo irgendwie 30.000 Schlüssel drin sind.
Also ich hab gerade noch ein Foto geschaut, ich hab's leider nicht gesehen. Eine Hausecke, die ich mal fotografiert habe, an der sieben solche Schlüsseltresoren erwandt waren. Das sah etwas durchlöchert aus und wild, weil es war bei jedem Schlüsseltresor ein anderes Produkt, Größe, Farbe, Bauform.
Okay, das heißt man sollte sich mal erkundigen, was im Schlüsseltresor drin liegt und welches Fabrikat das Schloss ist, was den Schlüsseltresor verschließt.
Wenn man ruhig schlafen möchte, lieber nicht.
Okay, dann lass ich das lieber und nehme stattdessen den Ray. Hallo, guten Abend. Du bist auch vom Chaos Computer Club allerdings aus München.
Genau, ich bin hier vom Tätig in München und ich wollte mal anrufen, ein bisschen was über unsere Schließanlage erzählen, weil wir einen elektronischen Selbstbau bei uns verwenden. Ja, ich werde erst mal kurz zur Motivation. Ich meine, ihr habt ja schon ein bisschen über elektronische Schließsysteme geredet.
Sind alle Scheiße.
Die größte natürlich mechanisch ist erstmal Scheiß, haben viele Schwächen. Und der große Kritikpunkt, den wir natürlich hatten als CCC, ist, dass die alle keine Open Source Krypto verwenden. Wir haben auch auf Schlossmessen, dass wir in München die Security, das ist ab und zu, wo viele Hersteller sich die Hand geben, haben mal Hersteller angesprochen, wollten nicht mal einen offenen Krypto verwenden. Ich meine, alle Online-Banken-Systeme verwenden offenen Krypto, das kann so schlecht nicht sein. Aber die haben offenbar alle riesige Angst davor, dass wenn der Krypto bekannt ist, das irgendwie ihrem Ansehen schadet.
Na vor allen Dingen ist es weniger ein Schutz gegen Einbrecher bei diesem System, sondern in der Regel ist es ein Schutz vor den eigenen Kunden, dass man Kundenbindung hat, dass man nämlich Nachschlüssel oder zusätzliche Karten nur vom gleichen Hersteller beziehen kann.
Genau, da könnte sich jemand am Ende eigene Tokens machen, den ich die tollste Programmiersoftware verwende oder irgendwie sowas. Aber die verkaufen das natürlich als Sicherheitsfeature. Meine Lieblingsaussage wäre, sie wäre ganz stolz darauf, dass selbst das BSI nicht den ganzen Code gesehen hat. Also das ist wirklich so. Mit NDA geben wir ein bisschen raus, aber niemanden haben wir bisher alles gegeben. Und das ist einfach sowas von lächerlich, dass wir gesagt haben, es gibt kein einziges kommerzielles Produkt, das man verwenden kann. Das Problem ist, es gibt halt auch kein einziges mechanisches Produkt, das man verwenden kann, weil gerade, wenn man so einen Clubraum oder sowas hat, da kommen Schlüssel gehen verloren und mechanische Schlüssel kann man nicht ungültig machen.
Und wie habt ihr es dann letztendlich gelöst?
Und dann haben wir gesagt, wir brauchen Elektronik und wir müssen sie selber programmieren. Und wir haben dann im Prinzip, gut, wir haben noch ein Schloss in der Tür, aber wir haben gesagt, Elektronik kann auch versagen. Aber dieses Schloss ist ein relativ sicheres und der Schlüssel hängt halt irgendwo hinterlegt, in Bankschließfächern versiegelt und so weiter und wird hoffentlich nie gebraucht. Und an der Innenseite des Schlosses haben wir so einen Motor montiert, den gibt es sogar als Fertigprodukt relativ billig für den für den Heimbereich. Der ist original so gedacht, dass man den mit so einem Funkschlüssel bedient und dann tut er den Motor aufmachen. Also quasi arme Leute, Funkschließung. Die haben wir natürlich erst mal komplett abgeklemmt, weil das ist wahrscheinlich auch mindestens genauso sicher. Ich nehme an, das macht 433 MHz unverschlüsselt oder so was. Da will ich jetzt nicht gesagt haben, aber auf jeden Fall kann man die Menschen nicht trauen. Und haben stattdessen dann den Mikrocontroller dran gehängt, den wir mit einer Foneira ansteuern.
Mit einer was?
Mit einer Foneira, das ist so ein WLAN Router, den man schön mit Linux versehen kann. Und jetzt haben wir es halt so gemacht, dass jeder einen SSH-Schlüssel hat, den er auf sein Handy spielen kann, da hat er seinen Putty drauf oder so was. Und wenn man sich mit einem bestimmten Login und seinem SSH-Schlüssel identifiziert, dann wird halt über den Mikrocontroller dieser Motor angesteuert und die Tür geht auf.
Oh mein Gott, das ist aber nicht total kompliziert. Also Stichwort User-Aczeptanz, das heute schon mal bei Netzhaut-Fotografie gefallen ist.
Ja, also sagen wir, das ist immer ein Essen, ist natürlich mit dem Handy die Tür aufsperren unter, beim Chaos Club. Also das ist ja wohl die Geek-Aczeptanz schlechthin.
Okay, zugeben.
Was gibt es Cooleres? Ist natürlich ein bisschen umständlich, wobei man zusagen muss, man sperrt das natürlich nicht alle fünf Minuten auf und zu. In der Regel der Erste, der in den Club halt kommt, muss aufsperren.
Man kann die Tür von innen auch noch von Hand öffnen.
Man kann die, wenn sie einmal aufgesperrt ist ja sowieso. Wir sperren uns in der Regel nicht ein, wenn wir drinnen sitzen.
Alles klar.
Also man kann das natürlich innen aber auch an so einem Rad drehen. Und zum Zusperren haben wir es auch so gemacht, dass man gar keinen Schlüssel braucht, sondern kann man innen den Knopf drücken, dann ist auf Zusperren geschaltet und wenn man die Tür dann zufallen lässt, wird über den Riedkontakt erkannt und der Motor sperrt ab.
So, dann hier kleine sportliche Herausforderungen an die Damen und Herren aus Berlin. Wie sieht es denn aus? Wie angreifbar ist das System? Ich meine, ihr habt heute über jedes Schloss schon einen Angriff gefunden.
Na im Zweifelsfall Tür eintreten.
Ja, okay, abgesehen davon. Wir reden noch über zerstörungsfrei.
Man würde dann in dem Fall natürlich den Infoneer angreifen. Man weiß ja nicht, wie akkordlich Software ist, die da draufläuft und SSH hat ja in der Vergangenheit.
Eines der vielen Telefone, die dazu verwendet werden, das aufzumachen.
Genau, die Telefone, das haben wir ja auch jetzt häufiger gesehen.
Das ist natürlich ein Problem, wobei natürlich der Vorteil davon darauf ist, dass man einen SSH-Schlüssel in der Regel, und das ist bei uns eigentlich mal kürt, wir können es nicht überprüfen, man kann es natürlich abschalten, aber die Leute sollen natürlich ihren SSH-Key mit einem Passwort versehen. Das heißt, da ist eine Passphrase drauf und selbst wenn das Telefon in fremde Hände gerät, kann damit niemand was anfangen, was natürlich nochmal ein deutlicher Vorteil gegenüber einem normalen Schlüssel ist, wenn der in seltsche Hände kommt, ist der in Sekunden kopiert.
Man muss schon einen Mobile Banking Trojaner umbauen, dass er die SSH Passphrase auch hinschreibt.
Das ist immerhin schon mal eine Herausforderung, die alles, was an normalen Schließsystemen vorhanden ist, mal übersteigt. Der Punkt ist, es hat auch einen mechanischen Schlüssel. Wir haben ja in München auch aktive SSDEV Gruppe, die auf der letzten H auch über mechanische Schließsysteme und deren Nachmachen referiert hat. Und es gibt quasi überhaupt kein mechanisches Schließsystem mehr, wo man nicht in der Lage ist, einen Schlüssel zu kopieren, unerlaubt. Ja, das heißt, wenn man einen Schlüssel in die Hand bekommt, normalerweise ist er eine Sicherungskarte, der Schlüsseldienst kann den nicht nachmachen und so weiter. Aber alle verfügbaren mechanischen Schlüssel, also ich weiß nicht, Ausnahmen möchte es geben, aber eigentlich alles, was wir kennen, kriegt man ohne Hilfe des Herstellers kopiert. Also wenn ein Schlüssel auch nur kurze Zeit in fremder Hand ist, kann man davon ausgehen, dass eine Kopie existiert.
Also das übliche Verfahren ist, dass man so einen Abdruck macht in einer Masse, die nicht unähnlich der ist, die man immer ins Gesicht geschmiert bekommt, wenn man irgendwie, keine Ahnung, eine Zahnspange oder eine Krone oder sowas beim Zahnarzt bekommt.
Die Abgussmethode, es gibt auch Sachen, die haben Magnete drin. Die galt jetzt vor kurzem als unkopierbar. Damals ein bisschen mit beschäftigt, haben sie das auch hinbekommen. Das war was wir auf der H vorgestellt haben.
Also es gibt Schlüssel, da sind Magneten drin, die machen was?
Da sind Magneten drin, genau. Und deren Orientierung, und das ist nicht nur aus Süd, sondern es sind so gedrehte Magneten, gibt den Schließchord an. Da gibt es theoretisch dann auch 16 Millionen Schließungen. Und man kann sie halt optisch nicht auslesen, aber man kann eine Magnetlesekarte drauflegen und so weiter. Also die Quintessenz ist einfach, keines dieser mechanischen Systeme ist nicht kopierbar.
Was hast du für ein Schloss an der Wohnungstür?
In der Wohnung hab ich ja nichts Gewichtiges. Da hab ich ein ganz normales, normales Standeileinschloss.
Da hast du dein Handy, mit dem der Club aufgeht.
Na gut, damit beschäftigen wir uns das nächste Mal.
Aber zu dem Punktureintreten habt ihr natürlich recht, das Mechanische ist natürlich immer, was man, sag ich mal, Niederrangigter betrachtet. Uns ging es erst mal darum, dass wir sagen wollen, wir wollen erkennen, wenn jemand im Club war. Also, dass man Fenster eintreten kann. Wir sind jetzt nicht im 10. Stock oder so was. Da kann man Fenster einschlagen, man kann die Tür sicherlich eintreten mit genug Gewalt. Das geht ja quasi immer. Ein so gesichertes Gebäude gibt es ja quasi kaum.
Das müsste erst noch gebaut werden.
Muss man... Muss man ja auch bevor der Rechner aufgeht, oder?
Das stimmt. Na denn, viel Spaß und bis dann.
Danke schön.
So, und dann haben wir noch den Sven. Der hat noch eine Frage. Tja, da hat wohl irgendwas nicht funktioniert. Möglicherweise ist das irgendwie auch die Telefonlage. Hallo Sven.
Bin ich noch in der Leitung?
Ah, da ist er.
Du hast noch eine Frage.
Ein Kollege von mir wohnt in einem modernen Haus. Es sieht so aus, dass die Mieter alle einen Schlüssel für die Wohnungstür haben und auch einen für die Hoftür. Das ist also der gleiche Schlüssel. Manchens mit einem Schlüssel schließt man beide Türen. Und nun war die Situation die Folgende, dass neulich das Hoftürschloss fein säuberlich, störungsfrei ausgebaut und geklaut wurde. Jetzt fragen sich die Mieter so ein bisschen, kann man, wenn man das Ding hat, im stillen Kämmerlein ganz in Ruhe Nachschlüsse für die Wohnungstür entfalten?
Ja, natürlich. Also wenn man an das Profil rankommt, wie immer.
Theoretisch, man kann daraus mögliche Schlüssel rausfinden, aber explizit keinen konkreten für diese Wohnung.
Achso. Du könntest jetzt nicht sagen, ich möchte jetzt für die Wohnung um vierten Schloss den Schlüssel nachbauen, aber du könntest rausfinden, welche Arten von Schlüssel benutzt werden und damit könntest du sozusagen Rohling fürs Bumping bauen, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Aber das wirft eine ganz andere, interessante Frage auf. Es gibt ja noch eine andere Öffnungstechnik aus dem Lockpickenbereich. Die sogenannte Impressionstechnik ist im breiten Volk nicht so ganz bekannt.
Da gab es mal diesen Russen, der in Brandenburg aus dem Knast getürmt ist mit der Methode.
Okay, Impressionstechnik.
Wie funktioniert das?
Er hat sich aus einem Stückchen Klochschüssel einen Schlüsselrohling gefeilt. Also es funktioniert so, wenn du einen Schlüssel reinsteckst, der jetzt nicht passt, und du versuchst ihn hin und her zu bewegen, dann fangen diese Stifte an, auf der Oberfläche des Schlüssels zu kratzen. Und dann siehst du, dass es da gekratzt hat, dann feilst du ein Stückchen runter, dann machst du das noch mal, und irgendwann erwischst du den richtigen Abstand, sodass es sich drehen kann an der Stelle. Dann hinterlässt der Stift keine Kratzer mehr. Das heißt irgendwie reinstecken, ein bisschen schütteln, gucken, feilen, reinstecken, ein bisschen schütteln, gucken, feilen, bis das Schloss offen ist.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ein Generalschlüssel immer am wenigsten tief eingeschnitten ist. Dass man nicht durch Abfeilen einen höheren Wert den Schlüssel bekommen kann.
Ah ja, aber das Schloss könnte dann nur dazu, also das ausgebaut Schloss in diesem Fall, könnte nur dazu dienen, sozusagen den Schlüssel für dieses Schloss jetzt nachzubauen?
Nein, das weiß man sogar in der Art nicht, ob für dieses oder für irgendein anderes Schloss.
Aber wie soll das mit dem anderen Schloss funktionieren?
Naja, dieser Zylinder, der aus der Hoftür ausgebaut wird, ist ja ein Zentralzylinder, also wo viele verschiedene Schlüssel einschließen. Also wo ein breiter Schließkanal ist und mit Sicherheit auch unterschiedliche Plättchen. Und dadurch weiß man jetzt nicht, welcher Schlüssel, der da schließen könnte, ist wofür.
Das sieht man dem Schloss nicht an. Das heißt, ich baue alle Schlüssel, die sich mit diesem Schloss bauen lassen, dann komme ich möglicherweise noch irgendwo anders.
Richtig, also 20 verschiedene Schlüssel bauen, die alle genau dieses Schloss öffnen, was sie für andere Schlösser öffnen, weißt du nicht.
Aber was kannst du denn ausprobieren?
Ich habe noch eine Technik, wie man auf Schlüssel kommt, und zwar die wirklich guten Leute für die...
Warte mal, ich würde ehrlich sagen, Sven, deine Frage ist jetzt beantwortet. Super, dann viel Spaß damit. So, jetzt.
Also Impressioning hatten wir ja schon, da steckt man ins Schloss rein und wackelt, um zu sehen, wie weit man runterfallen muss. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass diese Tiefen der Rillen, also der Vertiefungen in dem Schloss, die können nicht beliebig sein, sondern gibt es dann von 0 bis 9 und auch entsprechende Stiftlängen nur. Und es gibt Leute, die können also einem Schlüssel ansehen, wie tief der eingefällt wurde. Das heißt, wenn dein Schlüssel rumliegt, gucken die kurz drauf, dann sehen die irgendwie 68427. Dann können die einen Schlüsselholing in die Hand nehmen, dann fallen sie kurz 62487 rein und machen deine Tür auf.
Okay, das sind aber dann so Ausnahmetalente, so fotografisches, gedächtnismäßig oder wie?
Oder Leute mit ganz viel langer Weile.
Aber sind diese Abstände überall gleich sozusagen? Oder sind die dann wieder von Schlüsselart zu Schlüsselart unterschiedlich?
Pro Schlosstyp schon.
Also Hersteller zu Hersteller mindestens, aber teilweise auch in unterschiedlichen Produkten beim selben Hersteller abweichend.
Okay, das heißt also, wenn jemand wirklich viel Zeit hat, dann kann man das machen. Gibt es noch was?
Ich glaube, Öffnungsmethoden bin ich jetzt erstmal durch.
Das mit dem Schlüssel nachmachen, also an den Schlüssel kommen, ist natürlich ganz klassisch, genau über den Finger drücken, teleobjektiv, Schlüssel fotografieren, da gab es ja auch schon einige schöne Demonstrationen. Da braucht man auch kein fotografisches Gedächtnis für dann mehr.
Exotische Schlüssel und Schlosstypen hätte ich noch anzubieten als Tagesordnungspunkt. Zum Beispiel in Berlin, teilweise noch verbreitet, sind sogenannte Durchsteckschlüssel. Das ist selten geworden, gibt es aber immer noch.
Für Haustüren, ne?
Für Haustüren, ja. Du kennst das, ne?
Ja, wo man nicht, wenn die zugeschlossen wurde einmal, da kann man nicht mehr durch die Tür gehen, ohne da irgendwie auszuschließen. Du schließt auf auf der einen Seite, musst den Schlüssel dann durchstecken und dann schließt du wieder zu und dann kannst du ihn erst wieder rausnehmen.
Genau, man kriegt ihn nur raus, wenn das Schloss abgeschlossen ist. Man kann ihn aber auf die andere Seite der Tür schieben, dass man auf der einen Seite aufschließen kann, rumlaufen und auf der anderen Seite wieder rein.
Richtig, und dann haben diese Schlösser noch ein ganz anderes, raffiniertes, kleines Detail. Und zwar ist in dem Schloss, hinter dem sogenannten Stulb, wo die Falle und der Riegel rauskommen, ein kleiner Hebel. Und in dem Schließblech, also da wo das dann einschließt, ist ein Magnet. Und nur wenn die Tür zu ist, wird durch diese Magnet, dieser kleine Hebel angezogen. Und nur dann kann man schließen. Also bei diesen Durchsteckschlössern ist es so, dass wenn die Tür offen ist, kann man nicht schließen wie bei anderen Schlüsseln, weil dann dieser Hebel sperrt.
Gibt es auch besondere Angriffsmethoden, zum Beispiel für Leute, die genervt sind vor den Durchsteckschlössern? Weil das ja oft bei Häusern sind, wo der Hauswirt dann irgendwie 19 Uhr die Haustür abschliesst.
Ja, man hat da doch gerade angedeutet, man nimmt einen kleinen Magneten, weil dann kann man die Tür auch abschließen, während sie eigentlich gar nicht zu ist und kriegt den Schlüssel raus.
Oder flacher Pfeil.
Okay, so schnell habe ich jetzt nicht mehr geschaltet. Sorry. Jetzt haben wir noch ganz schnell zwei Leute. Tim? Ganz schnell.
Bei uns war es einmal so, da ist die Tür zugefallen. Dann haben wir, weil quasi bei uns es so ist, dass der Türrahmen von außen über die Tür rüber geht, bis zu einem gewissen Grad, das quasi angebohrt auf Höhe des Schnappers und dann einfach mit dem Schraubenzieher den Schnapper reingedrückt und aufgemacht.
Das ist richtig. Das wird auch von vielen verwendet. Wir benutzen es zum Beispiel gar nicht, weil es ja wieder eine Beschädigung des Strahlens darstellt.
Und außerdem braucht man dafür auch eine Bohrmaschine mit Strom.
Naja, Bohrmaschinen mit Akku sind relativ wenig. Aber das Problem ist selbst, wenn man zu spachtelt oder schmiert, meistens dann sehr sporadisch oder hässlich, dann sieht man das. Und der nächste braucht dann wirklich nur noch dadurch piken, durch die wahrscheinlich weiche Zuschmiermasse.
Aber ihr habt das sozusagen gemacht, weil ihr häufiger vor dem Problem standet. Hab ich das richtig verstanden?
Genau das meinte ich.
Irgendwie hat sich die Tür verzogen oder so.
Da haben wir noch mal zwei extra Löcher gemacht.
Sehr gut. Na dann viel Spaß mit dem Schraubenzieher, dem Loch in der Tür. Das war der Tim und dann haben wir zum Schluss noch Manu. Hallo.
Hallo.
Du hast auch noch eine Methode zum Schloss eröffnen.
Ja, und da müsst ihr immer die Dings aufmachen, da müsst ihr eine Cola-Flasche, müsst richtig Coca-Cola nehmen. Und immer von oben reinfahren und dann kriegt ihr das Schloss mit rum, weil die ist irgendwie so komisch gewölbt und durch das schräge Abschneiden kriegt man das dann wieder auf.
Hab ich jetzt nicht verstanden.
Ich auch nicht.
Wenn du von Coca-Cola oben so ein Stück abschneidest, musst du das einmal halbieren und da kannst du das in der Tür reinfahren und da hast du die Rundung drum und dann einmal runterziehen und durch die Schräge kriegst du das Schloss dann auf.
Sozusagen statt der Karte eine Coca-Cola-Flasche.
Richtig, das hatten wir schon angesprochen. Das geht in der Tat, weil das Material der Cola-Flasche dafür sehr gut geeignet ist.
Also es kommt drauf an, ich hab schon probiert, es war natürlich keine Coca-Cola-Flasche, sondern was ich nur gerade dabei hatte, es war aber auch gerundetes Plastik und es hat nicht funktioniert.
Daran hat es gelegen.
Zum allerletzten möchte ich zu einem letzten Typ Schlösser kommen, das sind diese Notebook-Schlösser, mit denen man sozusagen Notebook an der Bibliothek oder an der Uni anschließen kann. Da gab es vor ein paar Jahren diesen schönen Hack mit dem Klopapier. Einfach ein Stück festes Pappe reinnehmen und solange wackeln, wie es das Schloss von alleine aufspringt.
Oder Stifthülsen gehen dafür wohl auch ganz toll.
Ist das immer noch so?
Ja.
Würde ich davon ausgehen?
Also die haben sich das...
Das ist prinzipbedingt.
Aber das war noch zu sagen, damals gab es auch irgendwie tausende YouTube-Videos und ich dachte, da hätten die sich hier mal was Neues ausgedacht.
Ja, glaubst du, davon sie verkaufszahlen, dieser Schlösser zurückgegangen?
Nein, und ich dachte, das liegt daran, dass sie sich was Neues ausgedacht haben. Nein.
Ah, du hast zu viel gedacht.
Ja, das könnte möglicherweise der Fall gewesen sein. Gut, jetzt haben wir noch quasi zwei Minuten. Was empfiehlt man jetzt? Am Ende eines solchen Chaosradios stehen wir mal da und denken so, okay, es ist alles kaputt. Deswegen möchte ich sozusagen nochmal die Frage vom Anfang wiederholen. Wir müssen jetzt nicht irgendwie alle Angst erfüllt hinter unseren Wohnungstüren kauern und denken, oh Gott, da kommt gleich jemand rein.
Also ganz wichtig ist auf jeden Fall zweimal abschließen. Viele Leute gehen einfach runter und ziehen die Tür hinter sich zu, weil sie ja nun mal einkaufen gehen. Abschließen hilft doch deutlich gegen viele der leichten Öffnungsmethoden, die wir besprochen haben, dieses Ganze mit dem Karte reinstecken und dem Draht und der Cola-Flasche. Das sind ja alles zugezogene Türen. Das ist ein Druckschluss und viele sind einfach zu faul. Diese Faulheit muss man schon mal abstellen.
Und dann, du sagtest gerade zweimal zuschließen. Warum nicht nur einmal?
Dann muss man zweimal picken.
Na ja, da gibt es auch Techniken für. Aber prinzipiell erstmal ja. Und zweitens kommt der Riegel dann auch weiter raus. Und streng genommen, versicherungstechnisch ist auch nur eine Tür versichert, die abgeschlossen ist. Und abgeschlossen heißt, dass der Riegel 21 oder 20 Millimeter ausgeschlossen ist. Und das ist in der Regel erst nach der zweiten Tour.
Das ist ja mal ein interessanter Fakt, den man sich noch mal hinter die Ohren schreiben kann. Also unter einmal zuschließen zahlt die Versicherung meistens nicht, weil dann der Schließriegel...
Wenn sie so genau darauf achten. Also so ist es streng genommen im Versicherungsgesetz. Und noch ein Trugschluss, also der Einbrecher kommt selten nachts. Die häufigste Einbruchsstunde ist zwischen 12 und 13 Uhr, weil die Leute einfach arbeiten oder in der Schule sind.
Das ist tatsächlich auch so. Also alle Einbrüche, von denen ich gehört habe in Wohnungen, sind auch alle tatsächlich tagsüber passiert, im Sinne von ich war nur kurz weg oder ich war arbeiten. Es ist eigentlich auch so, es gibt diese schöne Bauanweisheit, wie der Blitz schlägt niemals zweimal ein, wenn einmal eingebrochen wurde.
Definitiv nicht.
Das gilt da nicht, sondern da würde man eher nochmal wiederkommen, weil es schon einfach war.
Ja, gerade im Gewerbe werden Leute, wenn sie einmal besucht wurden, häufiger besucht, weil dann wissen sie ja, was drinnen ist und dann wissen sie, was sie so für Taschen brauchen und...
Erstmal gucken und dann nochmal wiederkommen. Na gut, wir hoffen, dass euch das nicht passiert. Das war das Chaosradio 164 mit Andreas, Henrik und Simon. Vielen Dank euch drei fürs Vorbeikommen. Und ihr könnt diese ganze Sendung natürlich nochmal hören als Podcast. Auf chaosradio.de geht ihr bestimmt irgendwie in den nächsten zwei Minuten online. Irgendjemand hat ja immer mitgeschnitten. Und sonst auch auf fritz.de, da gibt's nochmal den hochoffiziellen Podcast. Ich wünsche viel Spaß und gleich Nightfight mit Henrik Schröder. Der wird euch Punkrock um die Ohren hauen. Mir bleibt nur noch ein Spruch. Macht immer schön eure Backups. Schließt die Wohnungstür ab und lasst sie nicht überwachen.